[MUSIC PLAYING]
CARTER MORGAN: Welcome
to another episode
of "VME End to End," a show
where you have someone that's
a little skeptical of
VMs and someone that's
a little more enthusiastic
about them on the show
to hash out all things VM.
Brian, thanks so much
for being here today.
I've got a tricky one for you.
BRIAN DORSEY: OK, let's go.
CARTER MORGAN: Yeah.
Yeah, I want to know about
cutting edge technology,
like really pushing cloud
compute machines to the limit.
I think this is going to be
one that's going to trip us up.
BRIAN DORSEY: I have the
perfect person for us
to bring in and talk
to you about this.
I would like to introduce Emma.
Welcome, Emma.
EMMA HARUKA IWAO: Hi.
Thank you for having me today.
CARTER MORGAN: Yeah, so happy
to be able to talk with you.
If I'm not mistaken, you
made an amazing world record
breaking pi calculator using
Google Cloud and Compute, yes?
EMMA HARUKA IWAO:
Yes, it was in 2019.
So it's a little bit old.
But it was a world record.
CARTER MORGAN: Yes, can
we get an overview of that
project a little bit.
What was it?
EMMA HARUKA IWAO: Sure, so there
are competitions around pi.
The number begins
with 3.14 and people
try to calculate as
many digits as possible.
And world record
we did was three--
no, 31.4 trillion digits on
Google Cloud, using 25 machines
and spending 121 days and
100 terabytes of storage.
And we did that.
BRIAN DORSEY: But this scale is
why I wanted to invite Emma in,
because there's not a lot of
people that have run machines
full on for four
months straight,
and I think more interestingly,
kind of worked through where
the bottlenecks are in a
system when you try to do that.
Where were the bottlenecks
in this process?
EMMA HARUKA IWAO: Sure, so the
bottleneck was the storage.
So in order to calculate
pi, you need a lot
of storage, 107 terabytes.
But the amount you read
and write is enormous.
We wrote about nine
petabytes, I'm sorry,
eight petabytes and
read nine petabytes.
A petabyte is 1,000 terabytes.
So it's approximately
17,000 terabytes
of data you need to process.
And the storage I/O was
the biggest bottleneck.
CARTER MORGAN:
This is one-- this
is mind breaking to
me, because I would not
expect Cloud Compute to
be able to handle that.
Like that was my assumption
coming into this.
Was this one of the first
projects of its type
to do this, or is this like
commonplace in the cloud?
EMMA HARUKA IWAO: I think it's
getting more and more common
these days.
A lot of people just run
high performance computing,
these type of massive
workloads on cloud.
CARTER MORGAN: So
then, my question
would be, what are some
of the advantages of doing
this in the cloud?
Because if I did this on
prem, I kind of understand
what that looks
like a little bit.
I'd buy a lot of my
machines up front.
I would try and work
through it from there.
How does it look
like for the cloud?
EMMA HARUKA IWAO: So I think
the coolest part of using cloud
is you don't need to
choose which machine
or which architecture
to use up front.
So, for example, if you're
buying a physical machine
you actually need to decide
how many cores you're
getting, how much
storage you're assigning
to that machine, et
cetera, et cetera.
But with the cloud, you
can always try and test
different parameters.
For example, do I
need 100 gigabytes
of memory or 200 gigabytes?
Or do I need 64
cores, 128 cores?
You can try and test
these parameters
in the real environment.
BRIAN DORSEY: So you basically
do small versions of it
and kind of see
how much work you
get for a certain amount
of time and money,
and see how that turns out?
CARTER MORGAN: Wow,
this is really cool.
Something I'm
really curious about
is, OK, you said
this was in 2019
and it's not the new
record now, or whatever.
But what would be different if
you were coding the same thing?
Say you were trying to do 32
trillion digits of pi again.
What would change if you
took that same code base now
and just, I don't
know, could you
update it for some of the
compute technology now,
or what?
EMMA HARUKA IWAO:
Yeah, so with cloud
you can just change
the parameters
and use the latest CPUs
and machines we have today.
For example, we have the latest
Intel and AMD processors.
We have more memory per machine.
For example, the
biggest machine we have
is 11 terabytes of memory.
And we have newer
persistent disk types
that achieve lower cost
and higher throughput.
And we have increased
the network bandwidth
from 16 gigabits per second
to 100 gigabits per second.
So by using all
of these, I think
we can probably finish the
calculation in a quarter
of the time we did in 2019.
BRIAN DORSEY: OK, there's a
kind of a saying, time is money.
And at some level that's just
even more true in cloud, right?
So if you make something
faster it costs less to run.
So that's a big deal.
CARTER MORGAN: Can we actually
talk about that a little bit?
What was like, say, the
cost of this in 2019?
And then you said it's
four times faster?
What would the cost of it
look like now, just estimates?
EMMA HARUKA IWAO: Sure, so
if you don't work for Google,
you'd probably pay a
lot for this project.
And it was about
$300,000 to calculate pi,
if you paid the money,
as an external customer.
And you get half the
storage for half the price
today, achieve the
same bandwidth.
So that cut the cost about
30%, because the biggest cost
was the storage.
And we had the faster processor.
We can use the Intel Ice
Lake Xeon processors.
And we have increased
the network bandwidth.
So in combined, it
took about four months
to finish the calculation.
I think we can do something
between a month or probably
40-50 days.
So you pay less part time.
Like you pay less per hour,
and you finish the calculation
faster.
So by combining all
of these factors,
I think it's safe to say we'd
pay much, much less today.
BRIAN DORSEY: That's awesome.
So like same project over
time gets cheaper and cheaper.
That seems like a win.
But it seems like you also
did a lot of-- you know,
like there's a lot of variations
for how things could be done.
You talked about running
experiments, basically.
If people wanted to run
their own experiments
on their own software,
how would you
recommend they approach that?
EMMA HARUKA IWAO:
Sure, so there are
tons of configurations
and variables in cloud,
and probably with your software
you want to run in cloud.
And, of course, you can
automate some of the aspects
for your software.
And there is a tool to automate
that for cloud as well.
It's called
Infrastructure as a Code.
And we use tools like
Terraform and Pulumi
to actually write down all
the configuration parameters
as a script, and run it.
And the coolest part is you
can automate the deployment
and provisioning process.
So for example, if you want to
test with different CPU cores
like 2, 4, 8, 16,
32, 64, then you just
need to write a for loop and
run the script again and again,
and invoke the software,
and run the test for all
the combinations.
And that's what you
can do with the cloud.
CARTER MORGAN: Wow.
Yeah, like I can
totally see, again, I'm
still a little skeptical.
I'm blown away that
this is possible.
But I see the benefit of
being able to just say
let me try out all these
different configurations
for my workload.
And so I'm curious, what are
some other things that you
think are pretty cool about this
type of hardware, that might
not be obvious to
someone like me who
doesn't do this kind of
stuff as deeply as you do?
EMMA HARUKA IWAO:
Right, it's good.
You may think, hey, I
can get the same hardware
from a hardware store
or hardware vendor.
But it's actually not--
well, it's complicated,
because you buy hardware, right?
You buy a new machine and you
use it for three, four years,
right?
You don't need, you don't
buy a new server every month.
With the cloud, you just need
to shut down the machine,
change the configuration,
and reboot.
And then you get access
to the latest hardware
without paying any upfront cost.
So if you want to, say, use the
latest Xeon processor, or SSD,
or NVMe, or AMD
Milan, then you just
need to change
the configuration.
And then you keep all the
data, all the configurations,
and just get the latest
hardware for like free,
without any upfront cost.
So I think that's pretty cool.
Like you can actually
use the latest hardware
anytime on cloud.
And actually cloud
is one of the first,
earliest places to
support such, like,
latest generations of hardware.
CARTER MORGAN: Oh, man,
that killed my argument,
because I was just
going to be like, well,
why don't I just buy
the newest technology?
But a lot of times it
doesn't roll out as fast
like as it would to the cloud.
BRIAN DORSEY: And you
mentioned the networking
got a lot faster?
EMMA HARUKA IWAO: Yeah,
so network is faster.
Obviously, you have the
ethernet and the switch
and on top of rack switch
and the whole back end.
And I think the
cool part of cloud
is you don't need to think
about the actual fabric.
So we support 100 gigabits
per second for network.
And each machine can
actually communicate
to another machine with
100 gigabits per second,
regardless of their
physical position.
So like when you're actually
designing a physical data
center, you actually need
to think of those top rack
bandwidth and how you
distribute workloads,
so you get the full
bandwidth for each machine.
But with cloud, we design
the network in a way
that each machine can actually
achieve the full bisection
of bandwidth.
BRIAN DORSEY: OK, so
that's a whole thing,
like from an architecture
and planning standpoint,
you just don't even have to
worry about it, think about it.
CARTER MORGAN: This is
so interesting to me.
One thing I'm curious
about is if you
were going to do a project
like this in the future,
like if you were going to
try and go for another record
or something like that, would
you still use cloud computers,
or do you think you might switch
over and use something on prem,
something more dedicated?
EMMA HARUKA IWAO: I,
because I work for cloud,
I would use, obviously, there
are obviously pros and cons.
For example, if you want to
use a specific hardware set
or specific, for
example, if you want
to test a specific
piece of hardware,
then you might need
to still get access
to that specialty equipment.
But for like, I
think, I would say
99% of the workload
in the world,
you can just launch
a machine in cloud.
And because you don't know which
machine to buy before actually
getting the machine.
So for on premise hardware,
you kind of do the guesswork.
And I think this hardware
with this number of cores
and this much memory
sufficiently big enough,
and not too big, but
in sometimes use,
like you don't
have enough memory,
or you don't have
enough storage,
or you may need
to add some cores.
You never know.
And with the cloud you can
just test everything, right?
And you can always
change the configuration.
You can always add new hardware.
And, yeah, so you don't
need to choose and invest
at the beginning.
You just change and
adapt along the way.
BRIAN DORSEY: This is a
really interesting angle
on, people often say, if you're
kind of doing a batch workload,
then maybe that's
not the sweet spot.
But there's this up-front
like testing side of it,
where you're being
more scientific
and you're trying to figure
out what kind of computer
or what kind of arrangements
of the computers.
And you can do
all of those tests
in really short
durations, which makes
them affordable to do a wide
variety of them on cloud.
Thank you.
I'm in the middle of this
and that's an angle on this
that I hadn't been thinking of.
So I appreciate that.
CARTER MORGAN: Yeah.
Yo, Emma, thank you so much
for coming in and sharing
what you've been working
on and the way you're
able to push the cloud, you
know, cloud compute instances
to the extreme.
There's a lot that
I didn't think
was possible or didn't
know was possible.
And I hate to admit this,
Brian, the more we talk,
the more I start thinking cloud
computing makes a lot of sense.
BRIAN DORSEY: Imagine.
CARTER MORGAN: Well, yeah,
that's it for this episode.
Emma, thank you.
And if you're watching
at home, definitely
let us know of anything
that was surprising to you.
We definitely check
out all the comments.
And stay tuned for next episode,
because it's a special one.
I don't know what's in store,
but Brian said I can't miss it.
BRIAN DORSEY: Oh, we do.
It's going to be awesome.
And, yeah, so please
hang in there.
Check it out.
And if you're living
in the future already,
just hit Next on the
playlist and join us.
It'll be fun.
[MUSIC PLAYING]